thank you yeah it's great to be here
thanks to the organizers I should also
thank the organizers for their
flexibility because up until about two
weeks ago I said I would talk about
something else and I'm glad that they
let me switch over to this I saw that
there were a couple other talks related
to experiments and a/b testing and then
I also thought this would just be work
that would be potentially interesting to
this audience and it's a little bit of a
change of pace from you know most of the
other types of things you'll see this
week but but hopefully you'll find it
interesting
so some backstory to this this is
actually not work that I did through
Stanford this is work that I did with a
company called Optimizely which runs a
large AV testing platform basically just
explain to you kind of what the backdrop
to the problem was I'm gonna skip this
slide I feel like most people here will
probably know what a B testing is
basically it's it's a mechanism that
online platforms used to compare
different versions of their websites
that's a narrow definition these days
it's essentially used for
experimentation in in every sort of
technology system that you could imagine
the basic idea is that you have two
persons of something you want to compare
and see a visitor is coming in and you
randomized them into either the
controller or the treatment this is like
the simplest example you track something
like a conversion rate in each group so
you know for example you might care
about how effective a particular design
is at convincing someone to buy a
product so you would be tracking the
conversion rate from arriving to the
page to actually buying the product you
could look at something like the true
conversion rates you know the true
underlying conversion rates in each
group as kind of the ground truth that
you're trying to get at and what you
care about is is there a difference or
not between the two groups so this is
kind of classic frequentist hypothesis
testing you have you have a null that
there's no difference an alternative
that there is a difference and you want
to essentially test that hypothesis I
think it's worth just pausing here for a
second because this drives people crazy
you know that like do I really care
about whether there's just a difference
or not a difference my entire talk is
going to be focused on sort of p-values
for this hypothesis testing problem but
as is kind of standard in statistics
there's a duality between p-values and
confidence intervals and in practice I
would say that confidence intervals are
the things that people actually care
more of
but I'm not going to talk about
confidence intervals during the talk at
all that would just add known more
notation without really any additional
technical understanding I'm happy to go
through that duality if someone's
interested later
yeah Bobby it's what's called a
composite yes a hypothesis one is just a
component what's called a composite
alternative that the theta is something
other than zero again oh sorry group by
group I mean the the true variations
controller treatment so when I say
conversion rates are tracked in each
group I mean you would measure the
conversion rate for all the visitors
that come into the control and all the
visitors that come into the treatment
and then you would compare these two I
mean more generally of course the data
in those is actually the entire sequence
of arrivals with whether or not they
converted you know it turns out that for
any reasonable testing purpose all
that's relevant as a sufficient
statistic is the is the fraction that
actually converted okay so if you go to
a stats book and you look up you know
how should you run such an experiment
and let me preface this also by saying I
think there are lots of really
interesting questions you could ask an
a/b testing and probably one of the most
interesting questions is is this even
the problem worth solving okay just in
the interest of time I'm not tackling
that question this would be largely a
philosophy talk in that case so I am
going to just essentially assume that
the problem I'm interested in solving is
kind of this hypothesis testing problem
and you know in a stats book and this
would be something you would learn and
kind of even an undergrad stats class
what you're taught is basically that you
pick your sample size in advance and
once you pick your sample size the
interface the a/b testing platform
interface will spit out for you
something called a p-value which is
essentially the probability of seeing
data as Extreme as what you saw given
the that the null is true okay so like
how you know the p-value is measuring
how likely is your data under the null
and then there's a simple decision rule
which tells you to reject the null if
that p-value falls below alpha okay so
this is the approach that's used in
virtually every a/b testing platform and
dashboard whether internal to a company
or external and you know one of the
reasons it's used I think it's
interesting because p-values obviously
have been attacked
Lesly for a variety of different reasons
I'm sure many of you are familiar with
this so I'm not I'm also not here to
offer a defense of p-values that would
be a separate philosophy talk I one of
the things I do think is worth doing
though before we completely reject them
is to ask ourselves why were they so
prominent or so useful in the first
place and I think one of the things
that's worth remembering here is that
this this is actually a very simple
decision rule and if you're trying to
design a platform that you want millions
of people to be able to use without
really having advanced training and
statistics then simplicity of a decision
rule is kind of an appealing property
and that's you know probably part of the
reason why this is something which
actually you know finds its way into
practice so easily despite kind of the
mess of understanding what this is
actually doing underneath and you know
if you if you dig into that a bit one of
the nice things about that decision rule
is when it is used correctly then you
actually get some very strong results so
you get the fact that type 1 error is
bounded at level alpha which means that
the probability of a false positive is
bounded at level alpha
it gives optimal power so true positive
probability given alpha assuming a
reasonable hypothesis test was used to
generate the the p-value and you know
these two things are given to you
essentially for free as a user without
really having to know anything about the
internals of the experiment or the
analysis methodology all that was really
needed was that p-value okay and so you
know one of the nice things for a
dashboard whether again internal to a
company or external as it as Optimizely
is one of the nice things about that is
that many different people are going to
be drawing inferences from the same data
right and so one of the I think appeals
of something like a p-value or
confidence interval is computed from
this type of methodology in a in an
organizational context is it allows many
different people with different risk
preferences to interpret the same data
without having the first kind of
unfilter you know someone else's someone
else's subjective beliefs from the data
you know I think I think there are ways
for organizations to intelligently build
Bayesian models of the same thing but
it's definitely not very prevalent and I
think this is part of the reason that
this is something which for better for
worse you know has has developed a sense
of being sort of objective as as people
use it so I think this is an important
thing it's certainly one of the reasons
I think that you know this coupled with
the simplicity of the decision rule is
one of the reasons that this is such a
pervasive approach to to testing but all
that was pretty you know predicated on
the presumption that these things are
used correctly they are not used
correctly that's what many of the
p-value hacking papers I'm sure you guys
have have heard about are all about and
you know here's an example I walk you
through why they're not used correctly
it's not just that they're not used
correctly it's that we encourage you to
not use them correctly okay so in
particular this is the this is an old
version of what the dashboard and
optimizing would have looked like for an
experiment and the thing I actually want
to point out to you here okay so you
know this is a test with actually
multiple variations so different cells
this is the control three different
treatments there's a number of different
metrics that are being tracked and and
here's your you know multiple hypotheses
being tested but the thing I actually
want to draw your attention is in this
really tiny blue font over here and it
says how long should I run my test now
what that does when you click on is it
takes you over to a sample size
calculator alright so what is that doing
it's saying tell me how long I need to
run the experiment now what did I just
tell you two slides ago the first thing
you learned in the stats book is to
figure out how long you're gonna run the
experiment before you run the experiment
so the place that should have been was
not on a results page it should have
been on a design page all right what if
why is it here it's here because
everybody asks how much longer do I have
to wait in this experiment right but
that is not at all what classic
experimental design is set up for you're
not supposed to be recalibrating the
sample size halfway through the test all
right so you know in in particular what
can happen is that one of the
Diagnostics Optimizely customers will
use to determine whether the platform is
doing something reasonable is to run
what's called an AAA test where they
just run the same version of the webpage
against itself because here you expect
the platform will tell you that there's
no difference and so they run the test
and what do they find they find wait a
second you know so this is actually one
minus the p-value at the time it was
something called chance to beat baseline
and that crossed 95% and if they're
using a 5% p-value cutoff then they'd be
like wait this is significant what's
going on so you know the poor customer
support reps we get these calls where
people are like I just ran a test and I
got a significant result you know I
don't trust your platform and and where
are the bugs in the algorithms you're
using and the truth is that just what
will happen is if you're willing to wait
right in that case didn't have to wait
very long but in general if you're
willing to wait every AAA test is
eventually going to return a false
positive okay that's just it's a simple
consequence of the law of the iterated
logarithm
you know if you if you look at this this
test statistic it's guaranteed to cross
any level infinitely often any fixed
level infinitely often okay and so
Taekwon error is guaranteed now that's
an asymptotic result but in fact even on
finite horizons so here we're talking
about like 10,000 visitors you know with
alphas of point 1.05 0.01 you still get
type 1 errors in the in the 30% range
okay with that rule you can be a little
more intelligent I won't talk about this
there's something called post hoc power
which essentially amounts to just using
an even lower alpha threshold cutoff for
your p-value and still you get very high
false positive rates so anecdotally the
the impression that Optimizely is that
probably just relying on those fixed
horizon p-values that are shown on the
dashboard and then applying this kind of
continuous monitoring people rounding up
with false positive rates in the 30 to
40 percent range right so this is
actually a fun thing for me because when
it happened naturally I turned to all of
my expert colleagues in the State
Department and the reaction of course is
that users are stupid so the right thing
to do is to give them a stats book and
then make sure that they that they
actually run their experiments correctly
and to be fair it wasn't just them it
was basically this is my response to it
was like at first this doesn't feel like
a problem
because this is a problem that the book
is so is solving for you right so why
are you doing it this way and I think
that kind of misses the point the reason
that people continuously monitor is
actually not because they're stupid it's
because there's a significant
opportunity cost of waiting and that's
just not something that was built into
the experimental design structure of the
platform right so in particular what
they really care about is that they're
they're considering okay if I wait am I
likely to detect an effect here because
if not I would rather run another test
so there's a high opportunity cost of
waiting and they're really making this
dynamic trade-off between detection and
runtime on the basis of what they see
and the reason they ask how much longer
do I have to wait on this test is
because given the data I've seen is it
worth it to wait or is it worth it just
to stop is it better to stop so that's
one thing and the other issue I think
that comes up for a platform is that
that's a risk preference that's not
known and not easily elicited so the way
that we're finding out about that is by
how people interact with the p-values
right basically if they choose to stop a
test at a given time then that's kind of
an indication that they've made a
relative trade-off between between
detection and runtime
at that point and so I guess the point
I'm trying to make is that you know for
us what we ended up with is that and I
guess I would say the main modeling
innovation and thinking about this
problem is to think of the user as an
actual participant in the process okay
so there's the platform that's
processing data there's sort of the
statistical measures that you're going
to display but then there's a user
that's actually a third party that you
don't completely control that interprets
the measures to take action all right
and so at some level it's almost like a
robust statistics problem where you're
trying to provide some robustness with
respect to this uncertainty about what
the user is actually going to do and so
the goal is to deliver essentially
optimal inference of the sort that I
described earlier for classical p-values
and confidence intervals in an
environment where users continuously
monitor experiments and when the
platform doesn't necessarily know the
users priorities regarding runtime and
detection in advance and I would say
that this is this is far too grand of a
claim I should have edited this down a
bit but our work tries to address this
challenge is a better way to put it I
don't think we're going to you know for
reasons you'll see it's it's going to be
difficult to do this kind of in in
absolute terms but I'll show you at
least what we came up with and you know
what the exciting things about this for
me at least was that it was a chance to
do some interesting sequential
hypothesis testing but actually see it
deployed so this is something which has
been running and Optimizely since
January of 2015 you know they have
thousands of customers worldwide those
of you that are surfing in the audience
right now are probably at a site where
Optimizely is enabled okay so let me
just quickly run through an outline of
the kinds of things I want to cover the
first thing I'm going to do and
basically as I walk through these things
what's going to be happening is we're
gonna go from a very general model of
user and data down to a much more
specific model of user and data so the
first thing I want to do is in a very
general user model try to control type
one error and as I said that's the first
thing that classical p-values gave you
the next thing I want to do is I want to
now given that fact I want to
efficiently trade off power and runtime
and here we're gonna have to make some
assumptions about the user model with
respect to which we do that okay um I
want to tell you a little bit about
exactly what the implementation meant
and here I want to talk a little bit
about you know sort of what do we learn
by looking at some of the data inside
Optimizely this I'm almost certainly not
going to have time to get to but I just
wanted to point it out which is that
alongside the work
which was really to change p-values and
confidence intervals so that they were
kind of sequentially valid so they were
valid under continuous monitoring we
also once you have p-values than many
statistical methods for correcting in
the presence of multiple hypothesis
testing become implementable and so one
of the things we try to do is ask you
know when can our new p-values commute
with classical multiple hypothesis
testing procedures so that I won't talk
about that much but that's kind of this
is also something that's deployed in the
in the commercial dashboard okay so let
me tell you about sort of our first oh
sorry yeah yeah yeah actually so this is
a great question so let me repeat your
question it was I think there was
actually two separate questions so one
is do I know the hypothesis the users
are testing and the other is could I do
something like a multi-armed bandit so
in terms of what the users the
hypothesis the users are testing the
assumption that is being made is that
the users are comparing each of the new
variations to the baseline now as I said
earlier like I could easily give an
hour-long talk on all the open problems
in AV testing and one of the biggest
ones by far is that you know if a user
has a web page and then creates five new
variations is it you know it's it's
unlikely that the thing they're most
interested in is a comparison of all of
those against the baseline often they're
going to care say for example for best
arm you know best arm identification
among those five or those six or they
may actually care about abandoned where
it's left continuously running and they
actually want to minimize regret over
time so I would you know again I think
it's a it's a great conversation to have
probably over a drink or coffee or
something but coffee is a drink I guess
but no but so as I say is that I think
it's a great conversation to have I
think for now I want to just focus in on
this narrow problem where we're still
maintaining the same structure I think
what I would say is that one of the
interesting challenges is that people
will often tell you that what they want
is the best of something until they find
out that the best wasn't the thing they
thought was going to be best and then
they want to know why that wasn't best
and that's inference so the problem is
retrospectively people want inference
and prospectively they want best arm
selection and the question is how do you
combine those two things it like you
know neither field is really well
to do the other well that's actually
some of the things I find interesting
right now okay so so let me talk about
this first which is how do we compute
p-values that kind of give us this
strong property which is a user can look
at the results whenever they want and
then if they happen to cut off the the
p-value at alpha at that point they
would still have valid type 1 error
control okay so we need to kind of make
that a little bit more formal and so
this is I guess one of the first
contributions in the paper is just this
definition of what that means so let's
go back to how p-values are classically
computed what this is saying is
basically that you commit in advanced a
little n to when you're going to look at
the p-value what I want the p-value to
have at that point is that it is super
uniform basically that if you cut the
p-value off at X and the null happen to
be true then you you know the p-value
will not fall below X more than fracture
next to the time okay this is exactly
type one error control in the classical
fixed horizon context now here what has
to happen though is that is that you
need to you need to commit to N in
advance so what I want to do is just
change n to a stopping time okay and so
our definition is that p-values are
always valid if the same thing holds but
with T being any stopping time and what
that buys you now is that the user can
look at the data first and then decide
whether they want to stop the test and
on the basis of that we're saying
nevertheless we still want type 1 error
control so among other things classical
p-values won't do this because as I told
you if you watch the p-value process as
defined let's say from a standard T test
or something then that's guaranteed to
cross any fixed threshold so let's say
that the user stopping rule is I will
stop the first time the p-value crosses
a threshold then of course they're going
to stop with probability 1 under the
null okay so our goal is to deliver
p-values that actually obey this much
stronger property that under any
stopping time chosen by the user
they still stop so basically the point
is that now the user can favorably bias
their choice of T based on the data
that's seen and we're trying to correct
for that okay it's necessarily very
conservative so you should expect that a
lot is lost for doing this and one of
our goals is going to be to not lose as
much as you think you might because you
did this so how do we construct these
always valid p-values and there's I mean
for those of you with with some stats
background here I'm sure that you've
made the connection over to sequential
testing already
so this this very much feels like a
sequential testing problem and you know
what is the sequential test just to fix
the formalism when I say sequential test
what I mean is it's a family of stopping
times indexed by alpha your type 1 error
control they have the property that
stops later when alpha is lower and it's
it bounds type 1 error okay so that the
T alpha test terminates with probability
at most alpha under the null right so
there's you know many sequential tests
and and we'll talk about one in
particular that we used in a second but
here's kind of the key thing for us
which is if you give me a sequential
test you know this family of stopping
times indexed by alpha let me define a
p-value which is the smallest alpha so
the Alpha level test would have stopped
by observation n okay then that
resulting p-value process is always
valid okay this is actually mostly just
an interchange of definitions the proof
is actually quite simple but I'm not
going to go through it so that I can go
through the rest of the things I want to
tell you it's it's a it's a fairly kind
of easy thing to show the nice thing
about this is it means that any time you
give me a sequential test I can produce
these all these valid p-values okay so
when in the first kind of iteration of
this this work in this talk that we did
we ran into a bit of trouble because
this makes it look like what we're doing
is converting the problem of this
interface design into sequential testing
so now we've got all these valid
p-values now we just need to construct a
sequential test one of things I don't
want you to forget though is that I'm
running a running thread throughout what
we're trying to do is that the user is
someone that we don't completely control
so while it's true that that there's
this duality between the always valid
p-value process is constructed here from
the sequential test in particular if the
user stops the first time that that
always valid p-value drops below alpha
then the resulting stopping time is
actually the sequential test is exactly
a sequential test so because of that
duality you might think well okay we can
just focus on sequential testing now the
problem is that not all users are going
to stop at T alpha in this case anyway
so the property that matters more to us
is that we have type 1 error control for
any stopping time right clearly
something should be lost if they don't
follow this natural decision rule but at
least we found we have valid type 1
error control for any stopping time
okay so that's the first piece of the
talk which is what we wanted to do is to
kind of maintain a simple dashboard that
you know users could behave exactly the
same way that they're behaving but which
now provides type one error control so
one of the nice things about it's
actually one of the things I like the
most is that almost everything about the
dashboard you know they made UI changes
more lit more for the sake of better
interface but actually the mechanics of
the dashboard showing p-values and
confidence intervals hasn't really
changed what we're doing is preserving
something which feels natural but just
making it valid making making the the
the process of rejections valid and so
what we're doing now and on the
dashboard is showing these always valid
P values computed from a particular
sequential toast yeah but if I'm a user
I might
abort the experiment because I see
there's no in fact yep and then the
sixth time everyone I see an effect and
I say oh yeah that's a good point so
I'll repeat that question so basically
he said that we're only focused on one
experiment here and to some extent
there's the same problem across many
experiments I totally agree with that so
you know in line with the theme of many
interesting questions and AV testing one
of the things I find most interesting is
that in comparison to let's say the
design of clinical trials where there's
a feedback loop but it's much slower and
there's a lot more policy involved they
may be testing there's a much faster
feedback loop between what you learned
from one experiment and what you do next
this turns out to be not exploited
nearly as much as I thought it would be
so it does suggest that there's really
interesting ways to combine
reinforcement learning with like some of
these interfaces so I think you could
think of the problem that the platform
is trying to solve is sort of
reinforcement learning problem together
with the user as far as I know nobody's
doing that sort of commercially in any
meaningful way at least treating a/b
testing that way but yeah I agree with
you I think I think what you said is a
great point this definitely doesn't
address it ok so ok so what have we done
we've controlled type one error okay now
as I said that's not really that's not
really the only goal you know going back
to the kind of users aren't stupid point
the reason that users stop early is
because they actually care about
detection and runtime
and the trade-off between them so what
we'd love to be able to do is say
something like you know we found a test
and the sequence of all these p-values
always valid p-values that are
simultaneously optimal for everybody and
you know of course that's not possible
I mean among other things consider a
user who just has a silly trade-off
between detection and runtime somebody
who prefers longer tests right and and
low detection like that doesn't make any
sense
so when we want to do is we want to
impose some structure on a user model
with respect to which we can prove
things okay and hopefully that user
model captures this trade-off in a way
that's semi meaningful so what we
thought was most interesting the axis
that we think is most interesting is
this axis where a user is thinking about
when should they end the test right so
we're so we're basically going to
consider users where we choose a method
of computing p-values the user observes
these p-values and wants to detect
whether nonzero effects exist so they're
testing this hypothesis and they stop
the first time the few people you falls
below an alpha but they're only willing
to wait up to a maximum runtime event
okay so our users are parameterized by
these two numbers alpha and M and M kind
of indexes their patients right so alpha
is a commitment to type one error and
there's a commitment to how long you're
willing to wait now you can see that for
any given structure of always valid
p-values this gives a decision rule the
user will apply in turn that's going to
completely determine what your power is
going to look like your ability to
detect effects will look like okay so
our question is going to be for these
types of users can we design tests that
do a reasonably good job that's the goal
so the question is what always valid
p-value processes deliver an efficient
trade-off between power and runtime
without advanced knowledge of this M and
even there I need to be kind of careful
because I'm not going to promise you
simultaneous optimality for all M we're
actually we're going to look at the
large AB regime and see if we can do
something which is kind of first-order
optimal so for the rest of this part of
the talk I'm just gonna assume a normal
state of one model with just one stream
of data just to keep life simple and so
in particular here I'm just getting a
sequence of observations that are iid
from a normal distribution with unknown
mean and I'm testing the mean of that
normal okay obviously an a/b testing I
have two streams some details on that
you can see see in the paper this
particular stuff
generalizes to single parameter
exponential families but that's again
just more notation for the purposes of
the talk okay so here's the test that we
use it's called the MS PRT it's not
something we invented it's actually part
of this beautiful literature on
sequential tests of power one from from
the 70s so it's a test due to Robinson
Sigmund by the way I gained a tremendous
appreciation for Robbin Sigmund and lye
after working in this topic I mean
obviously we all know line robins from
the multi invented paper and and they've
all done a lot of work on sequential
testing but there's this entire line of
work on sequential tests of power one
that really hasn't seen a lot of
activity in the last two decades that's
at least as deep as the rest of what
they've done so it's very impressive
anyway so here's how the test works the
notation here this is the likelihood
ratio after n observations of theta
against they do not okay and what I do
is I integrate that likelihood ratio
against a mixture distribution I'm
deliberately not calling it a prior here
though it does have an interpretation as
one and the idea is that when the
likelihood ratio of theta again stated
the theta naught is high it means that
theta is a lot more likely than theta
naught but I don't know in advance what
Thetas are possible and so I integrate
against this mixture distribution to
kind of consider all likelihood ratios
simultaneously right so the this is the
mixture sequential probability ratio
test the sequential probability ratio
test was one which just uses the
likelihood ratio and waits till that
hits boundaries so we're going to use
this mixture sequential
probability ratio test the MS PRT and
the way we stopped there define NS alpha
the stopping time for this test is when
the likelihood ratio of this mixture
likelihood ratio crosses 1 over alpha so
you're given your alpha I stop at the
first point at which it crosses 1 over
alpha and otherwise I continue
indefinitely ok so this test has some
nice properties the first thing is that
under the null the likelihood ratio is a
martingale okay and since it's a
martingale under the null this mixture
is also a martingale under the null and
so you can use standard sort of optional
stopping techniques to show that this
the the the probability that this ever
stops under the null is going to be
bounded by alpha okay and so that's the
control of type 1 error under the MS PRT
again not our result in addition it has
power 1 so it's guaranteed to detect any
true effect eventually ok now why is
that I'm not
going to have I'm not going to talk
about this in detail either because it's
it's not kind of the core of my talk but
the point is pretty simple it turns out
that the MSP RT has has a detection
threshold which you know like what was
the problem with the detection threshold
from a classical fixed horizon test it
wasn't that it wouldn't detect a true
effect it's that it would always cross
under the null right so your power is
actually okay it's that you were having
you know your type 1 error is way too
high it's it's a hundred percent so the
MS PRT kind of strikes a delicate
balancing act it makes sure that under
the null you don't cross the detection
threshold more than fraction alpha of
the time we're nevertheless it
guarantees that if the null is not true
you will certainly cross that detection
threshold okay and this really just
comes from looking at the bias in the
drift of the of that mixture likelihood
ratio this is for for any age that puts
support on all theta yeah so we use
actually a mixing distribution that's a
normal so that's fine but yeah you have
to be careful about that I said it's
quite interesting in the literature on
this the HS that are considered usually
have known no mass of zero so they they
they actually have zero density at zero
and that was one of the big differences
in what we're doing it's important to
put a lot of mass at zero because most
effects observed in a/b tests are going
to be around zero okay so so it's
guaranteed to detect any two effect
eventually and this is already pretty
good right because what this is telling
you is that you've got a test which
controls type one error and gives high
detection and in early versions of this
work this kind of all we emphasized but
that's not good enough
you know what I want to do is now I want
to use this and I want to think about
how runtime and power are being traded
off on shorter time intervals so one
thing I want to point out before we move
forward is that if you use the always
valid p-value process that comes from
this s alpha okay
which is basically stopped but the
p-value is the smallest alpha such that
the Alpha level test would have rejected
by now then actually that takes a very
simple form for the MS PRT it's just the
infimum of one over the likelihood
ratios up to this point okay and that's
really great because this turns out to
be computationally very simple it can be
done in browser for the client so it's
actually done on your web browser you
know as opposed to requiring kind of
complex computation one
great things about that is that then it
can be updated very very quickly and you
know as people are reloading pages and
so on okay so let me skip this this is
kind of the why it works but I think I'd
rather focus on some of the optimality
results so this is kind of what I was
getting at okay so it has power one
that's only asymptotically any infinite
data limit and there's not really it's
not it's not so much that that's in the
infinite data limit that's the problem
and so you're not getting a lot of
resolution there are a lot of tests of
power one and one of our questions would
be you know is it actually trading off
runtime and detection optimally right so
how could we how could we study that it
turns out to be kind of a delicate
problem and we want to be you know you
need to be a little careful how you
define efficiency here so what we want
to do is we want to I mean and you could
argue about this we're all theorists so
arguably I'm going to define efficiency
so I can prove something but I like to
think that the definition of efficiency
is also kind of a reasonable one so we
show that the mmm SPRT trades off power
and runtime efficiently even when a user
might have been in the test prematurely
so this is this user model I talked
about where the user is going to cut off
the p-value at alpha if it ever falls
below but if it doesn't they'll abandon
for sure at em they won't wait longer
than that okay so this is probably the
densest slide in the talk so here's how
I define efficiency given an eminent
alpha so that parametrize is the user ok
M is how long they're willing to wait
alpha is their type 1 error constraint
and an always valid p-value process I'm
gonna think about two things these are
these exactly correspond to power and
runtime the first one is the expected
runtime at a specific alternative theta
ok so this is if the true value happened
to be theta they follow this decision
rule how long would the test run and
then the second one is the false
negative probability which is really one
minus the power of the detection okay so
this is what is the chance that they
fail to detect that there was a true
effect despite the fact that there was
one and so you know this is what I just
said that we're going to assume the user
stops at the lesser of M or the first
time the p-value drops below alpha okay
so this is for our MSP RT with a
particular user model now what I'm going
to do is I'm going to compare that MSP
RT to a different test which obeys the
following two properties number one is
that it also controls type 1 error ok so
there's there's this hat test which has
a cue hat in our hat that also controls
type 1 error
it has the property that it's it's false
negative probability is you know is kind
of 1 over 1 plus Epsilon better than the
false positive probability of our m/s
PRT okay
overall theta so basically one way to
think about this is think about the
false positive probability as a profile
over theta here's a test which is doing
at least as good as ours and sometimes
better ok
so I'm giving it a band of 1 plus
epsilon 1 over 1 plus epsilon relative
to our test to do better well such a
test has to inflate runtime okay that's
what I want so what I want to be able to
show is that for any such test the run
times of that test expected runtime of
that test has to be more than 1 plus
epsilon times the expected runtime of
our test so informally what's happening
is that epsilon efficiency means the
power can't be appreciable increased
without significantly inflating runtime
okay and so what we do is our you know
our efficiency result basically
considers performance of the MSP RT in
the cheap data limit when M is large so
we what you know informally I would say
I would state what we're trying to do
here is show for users that have large m
we provide kind of an efficient
trade-off between runtime and detection
okay
and so how do we precisely state that
result consider a sequence of users with
a failure time that's going to infinity
and alpha K going to zero now why this
if alpha K doesn't go to zero you know
there's really no problem here right
basically you know everyone is going to
have perfect detection when alpha K
doesn't go to 0 when M K goes to
infinity so this is kind of the right
regime in which to study this trade-off
the MS PRT leads to epsilon efficient
always valid P values for sufficiently
large K provided that this bound holds
and what this is saying is that the user
should not be too conservative so if
alpha K is is too small relative to
their failure time that no test can
offer any detection any appreciable
detection okay and so this is kind of
the right scaling this essentially says
that this has this divided by M K has to
be bounded that's kind of the right
scaling at which the user is actually
getting detection so this is fairly
standard in the sequential testing
literature as kind of a regime in which
you would study performance for us
what's interesting is that we're trying
to deliver epsilon efficiency kind of
for all sufficiently large K the way I
think about this is there
you know most users of an a/b testing
platform are running tests with
thousands of observations there's many
user visitors coming in so that you know
that will fall well within the range of
what one thinks up is large and a
theorem like this all right so we
interpret this result as follows
users will have a range of risk
preferences encapsulated through alpha
and M what we first do is control type 1
error for all of them right and that was
the kind of first part of the talk that
was always valid p-values and this means
that you know doesn't matter who you are
and actually not only for all of them
but actually any user model type 1 error
is controlled ok some users are going to
be too conservative alpha will be too
small relative to their M and for them
however is going to be small under any
method any way so we don't optimize for
these users for the remainder alpha is
you know quote unquote reasonable
relative to m and among those we focus
on those with larger M ok and you know
for those users I would say the MS PRT
achieves an approximately efficient
trade-off between power and runtime
uniformly over theta that's kind of how
I would talk about the previous result
so one point about this anecdotally
anyway that I find really interesting is
that yeah I've always wondered like if I
was going to kind of tried to intuit
what the trade-off between alpha and M
is in practice how would I recover that
from what people in industry are doing
and one observation I would make you
know and Optimizely there's a very wide
range of customers some who get millions
of visitors into a test and some who get
thousands and so you can kind of see you
know what are the what kinds of effects
are they looking for what are they able
to detect and so on and you can talk to
them as well so one interesting like
thing I think is that in general
companies tend to be skating on exactly
this boundary and the reason it's kind
of obvious if you think about it if
alpha is too small you're not going to
detect anything anyway so that's kind of
not a useful exercise and
experimentation also if you're in a
regime where let's say you know alpha is
really large relative to your m then
you're going to get a lot of detections
very very quickly either those are all
going to be correct you know you got
lucky and despite the high false
positive threshold you you ended up
finding a lot of great things or you're
going to be wrong and discover that a
lot of that stuff is waste of time
either way you're going to rapidly find
yourself into a regime where the stuff
that you're testing you know are going
to be progressively smaller and smaller
effects and so you know your alpha your
alpha threshold it's going to go down
your m is going to get larger and so I
think one of the interesting things I
would love to maybe state a little more
precisely is that my
pression is that users find their way to
exactly kind of the trade-off between
alpha and that were that we're talking
about I mean it's it's sort of a natural
thing that would happen if you imagine
repeated experimentation in an
environment where you could choose alpha
and freely okay so I have two more
things I want to tell you I've got I
think ten more minutes is that right
yeah let me pause and ask if there's any
questions so far yeah we did actually
the the first model of this was a
cost-benefit model we essentially
modeled things through an explicit cost
to additional runtime and then you know
sort of view it as a standard decision
theory problem it's essentially
equivalent to what we did here I got to
be honest with you that what I
discovered was it was just harder to
give that talk so like one of the
reasons for that is slightly
idiosyncratic which is that the the
actual cost-benefit model that
corresponds to is one where the
additional cost to observations is only
in the h1 risk so if you consider if you
consider kind of what your cost looks
like under Nollan alternative you have a
cost to error in the null you have a
cost to error in the alternative it's
only in the alternative that you add
that additional cost on and this is
slightly this is any of synchronic for a
couple of reasons i mean the obvious one
is that right maybe the cost should be
there for both the reason it looks that
way is because there is an asymmetry
towards type one error I mean it's part
of the reason we're controlling type one
error first and that asymmetry is that
you default to preferring the existing
outcome so in some sense there's no cost
to observation there so that that's
that's exactly what corresponds to the
fact that we first control type one
error and then optimize the other two I
think you could do something similar by
adding cost in both places and you know
it would be kind of a different a
different approach from what I described
here probably related but I haven't
thought that through
you know you can say the name is drawn
from some sort of distribution and then
you know you don't think about it is yes
absolutely it does make sense yeah
so think about kind of average case
robustness against the user yeah we've
talked about that as kind of follow-up
to this but we haven't really proven
anything yet I think in some sense kind
of what this is saying is like think of
distributions which put most of the mass
out in the tail and we're saying
something about average case control
there I think like you know where it
really gets interesting obviously is
that you can see these distributions
that Optimizely that's why we got
interested in it but yeah we haven't
haven't proven anything in that
direction yet that's a great that's a
great kind of open question I think ok
so let me try to talk about the last two
things quickly so the first thing I want
to talk about is whoops okay the first
thing I want talk about is something
which is actually quite important
pragmatic concern so the theory is all
well and good but this is basically
showing is that essentially any mspr T
is kind of first order optimal in
trading off runtime and detection but
you have to be wondering like you know
that sort of feels a bit too slick
because that seems to completely ignore
away effect sizes right so how could it
be that you could pick any n eh you
wanted what if the mixing distribution
puts very low weight on effects that I
expect to see that can't possibly be a
good idea so how do I capture that okay
so one way I could capture that is to
actually do a bit more refined analysis
of runtime right and so what we do is we
say okay let's try to optimize runtime
but now under the assumption that the
effect is drawn from a prior
distribution so there's kind of a
Bayesian analysis of this of this
algorithm we're going to look at a prior
G for the effect size and aim to
minimize the expected run length
remember this R here is the expected run
length assuming that theta was the truth
for a user who has an eminent alpha and
now we're taking the expectation over
that against a prior where theta comes
from from G okay now the question is you
know how should we choose the mixing
distribution to to optimize this this
one length among the class of mspr T so
this is kind of like second-order
optimality I would say so when we show
basically not surprisingly is is that
the optimal choice of H depends on G and
in particular that the precise result is
that we look at the limit where alpha
goes to 0 and we show that the same
limit that I had earlier alpha going
I'm going to infinity and we showed the
optimal choice of mixing distribution in
the MS PRT involves roughly matching the
mixing variance which was Sigma squared
to the prior variance which is tau
squared okay and that's really nice
because we can measure a kind of a
pseudo version of this prior variance by
effect sizes that we see in the data
that's at least the approach we took so
what's nice about this is that if you
look at what the matching looks like the
matching between prior and prior
variance and mixing variance the
constant of proportionality is actually
something which is fairly robust across
ranges of alpha and at least what we saw
him carry is that if we if we you know
end up let's say you know getting the
constant you know the constant wrong
might like a factor of say 10 we're
still only like 5 percent off in
expected runtime ok so this is a fairly
insensitive so this is actually a pretty
nice thing which is that we were able to
find a way to actually specifically
choose the mixing distribution inside
the MSP RT to give good performance you
know on average across experiments that
people would run so this is almost this
is exactly what's implemented in the
Optimizely platform is a matching of the
mixing variants to the prior variance
alright so the last thing i want to talk
about now is just kind of oh yeah sorry
I've got it so do you mean are you sorry
are you asking theoretically or
practically practically yeah so so
obviously we don't you know the prior is
not something that we have access to but
the way we that we kind of construct a
proxy for it from empirically observed
effects and by that I mean actually so
good question so let me let me maybe go
into it for a minute you know if if you
look at the test that people run there
are many tests that people run longer
than any point at which you would
consider a reasonable detection
threshold and that's just because they
were left running they may have already
determined the winner and just left the
test running anyway so what we did was
that we analyzed sort of tests out to
these longer run lengths to construct
estimates of what we thought the the
prior distribution looks like one of the
nice things is that there's all kinds of
fudging happening there it's clear that
this is not going to be a good estimate
of the actual prior but the the I think
I again it's not a claim I could
theoretically prove but the errors in
that estimation are going to not affect
the optimality properties here
significantly because of the robustness
property of this of this runtime
minimization okay the last thing is then
let me just turn back into the platform
a little bit and I guess what I wanted
to do here it was just say if you had
been a user you know what would this
mean to you okay so one thing you should
understand of course is that if you have
to give up something right I mean it
says there's no there's no free lunch
here so if you had known the effect size
in advance then you should only be able
to do better by doing something like
what we're doing and in fact that's true
so when the effect size is known you can
use the standard SPRT of Walled and of
course that that's that you know that's
optimal in the strongest sense possible
it gives you minimum run length under
both the alternative and the null right
but the problem is that we don't know
the effect size in advance and the test
we design does not assume knowledge of
the effect size in advance it has this
mixing distribution but it doesn't
assume you know exactly what the effect
is so I guess at some level what I want
to do is I want to ask what's the effect
of uncertainty on the effect size and
you know that's the right place to do an
apples-to-apples comparison to fixed
rise in testing you know what do we get
when we compare so this graph
let me let me interpret it for you
x axis is multiples okay the y axis is
it's a histogram of over many
experiments I think there were 40,000
experiments that we looked at here these
were all experiments of the sort in my
answer to commish
where they ran for a very long time
relative to whatever would have been a
reasonable detection time so you can
think of it as having like free data on
which to simulate whatever testing
approach you wanted so on those tests
what we did first is we said okay let's
treat the final observed effect sizes
the true effect and for that compute the
optimal sample size and run the fixed
horizon test and compare it to what we
do right and in our case what we get in
that's the solid black line sorry no
that's the the dotted line what you find
is that often we will inflate run links
significantly by a factor of two or even
three okay now why is that happening
that's because if you happen to know the
exact effect size then fixed tries and
test actually picks a pretty good sample
size and in this case you know where
we're picking heavily inflated run links
but now suppose that instead what I do
is I imagine that when I picked out my
sample size for the fixed tries to test
I did so under the assumption that the
effect was actually going to be smaller
than it really ended up being okay he
goes off by 30% or 50% this isn't
unreasonable in practice okay we're like
if you look at some of these tests the
conversion rate might have been 10% at
baseline you're looking for a half
percent effect now half percent it's
easy to imagine that in fact you're
going to be looking for like point three
or point seven or so point out three or
point oh seven so I think it's like now
I got that right the first time so you
know it's the kind of thing where you
can easily be off by by you know by by
30 or 50 percent in in that estimation
of the actual effect now if you are off
by that much notice what happens the run
length under our test suddenly starts
becoming much better relative to the
fixed rise in test right and what's
happening there is that if you were
uncertain about the effect size the
fixed horizon test is actually quite
conservative detecting an effective size
Delta takes the run length proportional
to 1 over Delta squared that's pretty
standard and so the penalty for guessing
wrong about Delta is very high if you
happen to pick your NDE - x - small
you're gonna end up with a run length
that's 4x - long okay in the fixed
horizon test whereas the sent the the
continuous test can here this monitoring
test will adjust for that and so the way
we kind of
you know show this theoretically as we
say okay let's look at a regime again
the same kind of regime where alpha goes
to zero n goes to infinity when we show
is if you truncate a test at theta n so
you give us the same number of samples
as a fixed horizon test we can wait
sorry sorry yeah so look at look at an
MSP Artie that's truncated with maximum
failure time which is order of the
fixture isin test we get the same power
as the fixed horizon test at a detection
time that's a little low event okay so
that that user model where he stops at a
failure time or the first time the
p-value drops below alpha that person is
going to stop in sort of time that's
little o of the fixed horizon run-length
in a world in which the effect size is
unknown in advance okay so from our
perspective what this meant was even if
you were a great user of the previous
Optimizely dashboard okay the fact that
effect sizes are unknown mean that
you're still probably going to be better
off using using detection from this this
approach yeah yeah so basically I'm not
I'm not spelling this out it's that it's
that same kind of it's it's the same
kind of scaling that I talked about
earlier this like log 1 over alpha over
in this is like log 1 over L that needs
to be little Oh Big O event ok sorry I'm
rushing a bit just running out of time
so I won't say much about this like I
said I you know I think the the main
point I would make here is that there a
variety of different approaches to
controlling for a multiple hypothesis
testing I showed you the dashboard
actually that dashboard it's amazing
you'll find it in every company where
there's this kind of matrix of greens
and Red's everybody that runs a/b tests
has dashboards that look like that it'll
be very standard to have maybe you know
30 to 50 cells in that dashboard so
you've got a multiple hypothesis testing
problem with 50 hypotheses a lot of the
nice thing you know about about the
Optimizely dashboard is because we're
generating a different calculation for
p-values we can combine that with
multiple testing corrections that are
that are fairly standard and so some of
the theory and the paper is just to make
sure that those Corrections commute in
for wait someone talk about that alright
so let me wrap up I guess you know one
of the one of the things I want to
emphasize from this work just zooming
out a little bit but I what I found
really exciting about in kind of the
types of problems that have got me
motivated moving forward is this idea of
introducing the user as a as a third
party into the analysis I think there's
just a lot of interesting questions that
pop up there it might appeal to me
because I come from a more mechanism
design background and so I'm accustomed
to thinking about you know sort of
designing against against users in the
platform and I think what's nice about
this is that you you know that the class
of problems where you think of a user as
having an objective function and now
you're delivering sort of statistical
output to them to achieve kind of a
desired optimal outcome jointly I think
that's actually fast right that'll apply
even for many of these kind of bandit
algorithms where people are intervening
in you know successive application of
the bandit and so you know so I think
like what I would love to be able to do
is sort of more work of this sort where
you're adapting statistical methodology
to act in partnership with the user as I
mentioned their additional results all
of this stuff kind of goes through with
confidence intervals there's a there's
an exacto ality between p-values and
confidence intervals then we have some
initial results on applying these always
valid p-values to actually get p-values
and confidence intervals for multi armed
bandits so I'm happy to talk about that
offline if you'd like okay and I guess
the last point is just this was launched
on January 20th 2015 and as I said in
the dashboard they provide always valid
p-values and the multiple testing thank
you
maybe a couple of questions so with this
thing can you now say how much longer do
you want to you need to run yeah
actually it's so I haven't checked
exactly what the current design of that
same page is like but now yes now we can
so in a sequential testing setting we
can make statements about expected run
time again we have to do that with
respect to an assumption about how the
user will behave so the specific
assumption we're making is the specific
thing we're trying to calculate is the
expected time until the test will
terminate under some guess about what we
think you know the the effect size is
actually going to look like so yeah
that's right so now though it's actually
meaningful and in particular the most
important thing is biasing their
decision on the basis of the display
that information is fine because it's
you know they're allowed to make data
dependent decisions next question there
any we need to obtain speakers oh sure
yes go Emily oh you have yours okay yep
I think any other questions perfect okay
thank you
another question